claymont de Souza is a proud businessman
his company and a Paris suburb has been
making restaurant furniture for three
decades but de Souza has to keep
investing in order to keep up with the
market for instance this new machine for
cutting wooden boards replaces three
older pieces of machinery this machine
brings us into the world of automation
and it's about time small and mid-sized
businesses and France don't have as many
robots as German SMEs for example that
allows them to be market leaders in
certain segments oh something like food
the machine costs 200 thousand euros de
Souza needed a loan to pay for it but he
was able to get credit more easily than
before the bank seemed to be more ready
to grant loans due to the flood of cash
that the ECB has been pumping into the
economy de Souza hopes to tap it again
soon then where is he alone we're going
to buy two other big machines that will
allow us to bundle more manufacturing
operations Yuriko D'Souza's is not an
isolated case since the ECB began
pumping 60 billion euros a month into
the market in March French banks have
been making more loans economists say
the effect in France is visible festival
he's due to all the liquidity in the
market interest rates are at historic
lows the government as well as private
individuals and corporations are able to
get loans more easily in addition the
value of the euro has declined our
exports are cheaper than before and
companies in the eurozone are more
competitive Paul says Francis economy is
predicted to grow by one point two
percent this year six times as much as
in 2014 but it's not known whether the
excess liquidity will continue to work
in the long term recorded TV zing of
quantitative easing is like doping no
one knows how long the policy can last
and what will happen when it stops will
it still continue to work or will the
economy
tag once again Julie but for now the
liquidity is allowing D'Souza to
continue to grow his business but he's
hoping for more support from the
government well not cool if he skinny
thick yekam grants businesses have to
face higher taxes and non wage costs
than in other countries io faccio new
lodi we've been saying that for years
sample but French politicians don't
listen to us mango iced mocha movies a
little tokyo for sale is equal passive
so de souza has to continue to try to
squeeze costs lower by replacing human
workers with more machines